[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui à tam tam une
réalité trop souvent deux fois misé
oublier celle du nord le nord du nord le
véritable toit du monde
on vous propose entre autres une page du
regard sur l'arctique et puis on va
redescendre un petit peu vers le sud sur
le 55e parallèle on vous parlait d'un
trait nommé chioui tin le vrai trait du
nord bonjour tout le monde
bonjour ici raymond des marteaux vous
avez bien compris donc stéphane parent
est en congé because les fêtes de fin
d'année et puis avec mon studio hi des
screen bonjour et les marie claude
simard bonjour bonjour
et puis en régie ce conte à la paire de
guerre nazis les deux pierre pierre tu
t'es mis en gestion et pierre révéla la
console audio messieurs merci beaucoup
irish qui est à la tête du site regard
sur l'arctique a indiqué pierre guy bois
qui va venir se joindre avec nous un peu
plus tard qui lui est secrétaire
national de rédaction à espace
autochtone regard sur l'arctique
si vous n'avez jamais vu ce site faut
absolument y aller ça vous écrivez ça en
lettres d'or sur vos tablettes de jeanne
pas beau ça nous met sous pression comme
ça c'est tout à fait une coproduction
cirque une polaire en je réponde à des
questions circumpolaire moi j'ai fait
beaucoup de dossiers à l'époque avant la
création de ce canton n'était encore
même seront en cours dans la socan à
l'international avec le consortium
circumpolaire mais la haye squint geek
le regard sur la petite à un diurétique
c'est votre territoire si votre monde
c'est bon écoutez jeu sans être
flagorneurs je dois dire que j'admire le
travail qu'elle fait c'est très très
comme un ennemi le projet de vraiment
faire quelque chose de se concentrer sur
le nord mais ç'a commencé il ya dix ans
et si vous souvenez de ça c'était à
l'époque où on a parlé beaucoup de la
fonte de la banquise
mais on dirait que le monde s'est
réveillé un petit pas pour comprendre
qui en arctique et que tout le
changement climatique va transformer les
choses et va transformer des vies des
gens qui vit dans le nord et au canada
c'est premièrement de les ignorer depuis
les premières nations
alors le projet qui mise en place pour
comprendre un petit peu les enjeux de
d'amplifier sa mais aussi de faire sans
un partenariat avec d'autres médias
parce que l'idée c'est que toutes les
enjeux les problématiques les défis qui
vit les légendes un anneau du canada
s'est partagé par les inuits du
groenland les a mis en scène un nouvelle
solide et c'est qu'avec toutes les
médias 2d polaire qui ont fait une
partenaire year et puis on partage nos
dossiers nos textes nos émissions des
radios pour que quand les gens va se
laisser et comme un peu regard sur tout
ce qui se passe sur l'économie et puis
on commence regarde seul article le côté
fera ses 2 du projet on a commencé sa
lié à peupler 6 7 ans et on commence
aussi d'avoir d'autres partenaires au
sirha du canada grands noms et aussi les
journaux communautaires comme la cuisant
au piano alors commence aussi d'avoir
les médias francophones dans la nord qui
compte eu lieu à la projet aussi lu
l'immédiat du boréon mais comment
accélérer comme en ont été les réactions
je pense à par exemple à des nations
très nordiques que sont par exemple la
norvège la suède la finlande est ce que
dès le départ on sait d'où et on
embarque avec ses 7 et est suprenant
passe quand c'est avec les médias on est
tous sont en cours mais le fait avec
sale et les médias qui sont basés dans
le nord tout le monde a dit il faut
faire ça parce que les médias on n'a pas
assez d'argent ici au canada juste aller
dans l'arctique canadienne c'est
extrêmement cher
c'est une fortune vraiment il faut dire
les vraies choses là et puis pour
vraiment faire d'avoir une regarde ce
qu'ont polaire sur les enjeux la seule
façon de le faire c'est que toutes les
médias se mettent ensemble et qui
partagent le travail et c'est ça on est
très fiers nous nos partenaires en
norvège en suède en finlande
parce que quand il ya comme un enjeu par
exemple l'exploitation des ressources
naturelles dans les cas autochtone on
peut voir que ces boss juste au canada
que c'est un impact mais tu vois des
amis vit la même chose en finançant la
halle et les amis vit la même chose dans
nos veines reçu en russie aussi et puis
on quand on voit que c'est vraiment
quelque chose que tout le monde vit
ensemble mais là on commence tu vois
c'est pas juste un petit problématique
ici mais c'est quelque chose que l'arche
dit marie-claude je ne joue pas pour un
truc en conversation et j'explique se
montre un peu plus tard les émissions de
cette limite
et ça c'est tout cela qu'on voit c'est
un sas et un grizzly si je comprends
bien ça c'est là on ne joue pas avec
monsieur non ça il faut habiter sept
mois je pense qu'aussi que quand on part
du grand nord on peut pas évacuer tout
l'enjeu des ressources naturelles un
changement climatique fera en sorte que
la grande on sera de plus en plus
accessible accessible aussi par des
grands bateaux etc
et évidemment il ya plusieurs pays qui
se disputent le monde et une hawks
dispute l'appartenance finalement du
nord alors que bon finalement on sait
que ce sont les peuples qui l'habitent
qui en sont les propriétaires
alors on risque d'avoir beaucoup de
transformations et quand tu es déjà par
deux des changements climatiques
non seulement y at il des changements
dans le climat mais ça intervient sur le
plan de la culture également qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'auparavant par exemple les inouk y
sont un petit peu plus au sud que vous
ne viendrez un peu plus tard se
sentaient lésés nous est par exemple
disait auparavant
on pourrait aller sur les lacs jusqu'au
15 mai ce n'est plus le cas donc vous
voyez les habitudes de chasse de
déplacement etc vont influencer aussi de
la culture la façon d'être désigné j'ai
vécu ça moi-même à celle écrit en 75
aller au milieu du lac jusqu'à la mi mai
même jusqu'au début juin on le faisait
dans le bas du fleuve
allez je viens vous réchauffement
climatique passage du morne nordouest
mais aussi perte de mode de vie
traditionnel adaptation une vitesse
épouvantable à l'arrivée de l'internet
des médias sociaux est instruite
ouais est ce qu'on a le temps c'est
l'est aussi avec toutes les pensionnats
autochtones et toutes les pertes culture
à cause de ça mais ce qu'on voit
maintenant et pourquoi il n'y a pas
beaucoup de celles de nos communautés
inuit dans le grand nord c'est que les
gens qui a grandi sur le terrain où il
dit avec toutes les transformations de
nos territoires du meet you le
comportement des animaux mais parce que
j'ai grandi sur le terrain je peux
m'adapter mais pour la jeunesse qui
était né dans nos communautés la
première génération destinée dans un
tumulte fx eux ils n'ont pas les
connaissances pour s'adapter aux
changements qui sont en train de voir
alors on voit déjà que la culture c'est
en train de dégrader à cause de les
pratiquer l'onia liste au canada mais le
changement climatique c'est s'accélère
tout ça et puis c'est pour ça que c'est
grave pour l'équipe n'était dans un an
quand vous êtes tombé dans la soupe de
regard sur la bioéthique
c'était pas un territoire que vous
connaissiez vraiment vous avez vous avez
exploré de façon incroyable manger de
l'information vraiment oui mais pour moi
j'ai commencé ma carrière quand j'ai
commencé au yukon us à ceux des pompes
prévient jo bonne journaliste et puis
aussi j'ai travaillé aussi dans
l'article de la russie sogeti j'ai une
connaissance ces choses là c'est pour ça
que ça mixte et un projet comme ça je
comprends faut absolument parler de ce
plus récent projet ce plus récent
dossier chez vous qui sort ccc déchirant
cette histoire d'un père qui est à la
recherche d'informations de
compréhension il veut clore il veut que
pouvoir commencer un deuil mais il ya
des silences danse histoire là cet
incroyable
ramenez-nous à cette histoire alors il y
à peu près huit mois une jeune et nous
qu à cadix jack qui est un village
il nous est dans le nord du québec qui
se fait poignarder dans sa communauté il
a eu 19 ans et puis à peu près quatre
semaines après le père de cette jeune
homme la baignade ne m'a contacté pour
parler de peur juste ce qui est arrivé à
son fils mais toutes les difficultés
qu'il a pour savoir comment gérer tout
appris et il faut se rappeler au québec
qui est la commission vienne qui
viennent de se terminer ce mois ci qui
parlait de la relation entre les
premières nations les inuits avec les
services publics du québec
et puis ils veulent ou que moi je suis
de la famille pôle r&d pour expliquer
ces quads y vivent comme famille et au
québec en 2018 si c'est comme ça que le
projet a commencé et c'est c'est intense
cdu du très long terme ces huit mois
trahissent oui ouais alors on a parlé
beaucoup avant parce que c'est un petit
peu dans l'histoire
qu'est ce qu'on voit le présent
[Musique]
ou way déchirant - c'est déchirant et
pour ce père là c'était très courageux
c'est qu'il a été fait pour ouvrir sa
famille puis à tous les canadairs et
puis comme l'expliquent temps dans le
dossier il a fait ça parce que il dit
que la réalité dans la communauté c'est
souvent synthétiser c'est pas juste une
chose c'est une mélange de toutes les
choses ensemble so i faut dire que son
fils était poignardé motion johnny une
suscite dans la communauté
puis deux jours plus tard un attentat de
meurtre et puis c'est une chose après
l'autre
et puis comme on explique dans le
dossier toutes ses interactions avec le
système de justice
lemay compréhension de la système de la
justice
toutes les démarches avec les coronaires
les démarches pour essayer de trouver un
psychiatre pour sa famille c'est c'était
comme un cauchemar c'est difficile dé
foi de quoi que ça arrive au canada
nice a des résonances dans certaines des
communautés autochtones ou sur lequel du
travail une saison où il s'est tout à
fait se porte sur la question de
l'administration de la justice pour les
premières nations et les inuit limited
et ont la meilleure façon d'illustrer
cette problématique assez la question
des femmes autochtones
assassinées et disparues qu'est ce qui
arrive est c'est à dire qu'une femme
autochtone disparaissait on allait voir
la police wazemmes à écouter ce deux
jours trois jours quatre jours pour le
pas vu à barreaux c'est une femme
autochtone c'est nécessairement une
prostituée une drogue est effectivement
il y avait 10 y avait cette
problématique là mais je me demande moi
si on habite outremont et qu'on voit au
poste de police local et qu'on dit
qu'une femme est disparu depuis deux
jours ci la pole à napoléon et agir de
la même façon donc ça prouve toute la
problématique que du droit et de
l'administration de la justice au canada
autrement dit on disposait en théorie
être des êtres égouts devant la justice
or dans l'administration de la justice
on s'aperçoit qu'avec les femmes
autochtones avec les autochtones en
général cette justice là ne fonctionne
pas ne fonctionne pas parce que d'un
côté la justice semble prendre sa non
pas la légère mais comment dire c'est à
dire que les prix jugés de la société
face aux autochtones ont été intégrées
par les services de police et par la
justice en tant que tel alors on se
retrouve avec des zones de non droit
bien sûr tout ça change mais vous voyez
par exemple et les je parlais de la
commission vient à la fois ghislain
picard
le président ou le chef de l'assemblée
des premières nations du québec et du
labrador à la fois viviane michel de
femmes autochtones du canada que du du
québec
les deux ont eu sensiblement le même
témoignage ils ont dit devant la
commission vient on a le droit à la
sécurité dans les territoires
autochtones soit 0 à la fois pour les
femmes la fois pour les enfants est à la
fois pour les autochtones et ensuite une
fois qu'on a ce droit la sécurité il
faut avoir le droit à l'accès à la
justice
quelqu un qu un problème de justice dans
actuellement est trimballée d'un côté
comme de l'autre a toujours les
problèmes aussi de langue que veut dire
le concept de culpabilité ou d'innocence
pour un autochtone dont son épaule alors
il très souvent on s'aperçoit ne sais
pas c'est le cas avec les inuit que les
ou lisez nous est pour pouvoir s'en
sortir le plus rapidement par ses bons
dire oui à tout alors ça il ya des cas
et c'est documenté et c'est vraiment ça
a été au coeur des témoignages de la
commission vient quand elle s'est
déplacée du côté du nunavik alors c'est
toute la question de l'administration de
justice canadien
dans les territoires autochtones qui
posait à la fois par la commission d
enquête sur les femmes disparues et
assassinées et la commission vieille que
fait on maintenant avec des autochtones
sur le plan de la justice
et si j'ose peut-être même reformuler
cette question que fait on avec les
autochtones c'est que fait-on de sorte
que la justice soit prise à bras le
corps par les autochtones
il ya ça aussi ça aussi ça pose tout un
problème parce que on se dit bon
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ça existe par
exemple des tribunaux autochtone est
basée sur la justice réparatrice mais
tout ça une limite bien sûr est ce que
la justice réparatrice est suffisant
dans le cas d'un meurtre moi je crois
que non dans le cas d'un vol alors
peut-être parce que justement tu rentres
dans une maison tu vole une voiture tu
brises la maison évidemment là tu dois
des réparations voisins et ça s'appelle
ministre et mais ailleurs qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on est rendu dans des
crimes durée c'est le cas par exemple du
témoignage de ce père dont le fils a été
assassiné
je crois que là on se retrouve aussi
face une justice qu'ils seraient
éventuellement purement autochtone est
ce que est ce que ça pourrait aller
jusqu'à justement juger quelqu'un pour
meurtre moi pour l'instant j'en doute
mais il ya effectivement des gens qui
croient que de plus en plus et ça ça
fait partie de cette démarche
d'autonomie gouvernementale dans lequel
sont les nations autochtones que les
autochtones pourrait au passage
également retrouvé une forme de justice
qui est qui est la leur à lui la
réaction du père depuis la mise en ligne
du reportage
[Musique]
car qu'est ce que je vais dire ça
pour lui ces reportages et puis là
raisons pour lesquelles qu'elle a
raconté son histoire c'est parce que dis
je il dit c'est dans notre reportage il
dit monfils et le nook et puis le canada
le québec qui sont fous de lui et pour
lui le fait qu' il ya comme ça cette
histoire il dit je pense pas que les
choses vont changer dans la communauté
je sais pas si on peut écouter le club
de mairie peut lire tout mais il dit
d'avoir l'histoire l'histoire des
machines
oui c'est un disque différent pour nous
de dévoiler ça devant tout le monde
il le fait maintenant personne pour dire
que ça n'arrive pas dans le kymi
notamment et on va discuter et 106
femmes lisent ou un sursaut survenant
dans le kentucky fried 9 non le snarr
arbitraire et tout le grand espace dans
le temps qu'elle prend pour répondre on
sent la douleur aussi - et puis une
chose quand guy à parler d'eux comme un
peu le contexte pour l'heure pour la
justice il faut se rappeler qu'au québec
pour la justice pour les inuits
il ya des reports depuis 96 qui était
fait sur le problématique
les rapports dit la même chose il ya
comme dans 96 un repos qui fait pour les
organisations inuites
puis il ya aussi le barreau du québec
qui ferait pas au lieu de trois ans sur
le même sujet les recommandations sont
souvent exactement la même chose
tous ces reports au dernier vingt ans
soulève les mêmes problèmes personne
prend l'action pour les régler et on
voit la frustration avec madame peu dur
tout et puis dans le texte et dans les
commissions les
enquête y rien qui change dans nos
communautés et puis dit des fois j'ai
l'impression scellé pour faire les
manchettes en au sud mais ils disent des
commissions et puis témoigner ou enquête
pour les femmes de se produire à signer
aussi aucune mission vient il participe
en espérant qu'un jour ça va changer les
choses et même l'ancienne mairesse dit
tout les discos que vous avez au sud du
canada ou du québec
je vois rien qui change dans ma
communauté et je pense qu'il faut
écouter plus le regarder qu'une unité ce
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le pays
parce que c'est pas le même discours
qu'on entend ici dans le sud
il possède toute la question des
services et de l'accompagnement des
familles qui sont victimes de crimes qui
on est très souvent avec les autochtones
ce qu'on dit cecab
évidemment ils sont privilégiés par an
dont 10 en or c'est faux
il y a eu jusqu'à maintenant quatre
décisions du tribunal des droits de la
personne au canada qui disent que les
enfants autochtones ont moins de
services que des enfants non autochtone
et 4/10 quatre décisions et on commence
à peine au gouvernement fédéral à mettre
des mesures en place pour faire en sorte
que les niveaux de service pour les
enfants pour l'accompagnement
psychologique etc en éducation comme en
santé pour qu'on puisse rejoindre le
niveau des services qu'on donne aux
autres canadiens
alors quand on a ce discours on dira ils
sont privilégiés c'est complètement fou
les chiffres disent le contraire et les
décisions des tribunaux ou s'ils disent
le contraire
ce dossier n'a été portée par une prof
de l'université mail ici à montréal qui
s'appelle cindy blackstock est elle-même
issue d'une premières nations de la
colombie-britannique
donc vous voyez c'est ainsi tout un
contexte où on a l'impression que les
autochtones que les et nous est que ces
gens là vivent dans des zones de non
droit et c'est particulièrement vrai
pour des nations autochtones qui n'ont
pas d'assez is territoriale qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que si
vous avez des assises territoriales vous
pouvez toujours négocier avec
hydro-québec des rénovations
mais si vous êtes une communauté comme
keats et sa clique
vous n'avez pas d'assise territoriales
on vous reconnaît même pas le statut de
réserve alors vous ramassez dans un lieu
où vous n'avez aucun rapport de force
politique
vous n'avez pas d'eau potable vous
n'avez aucun service musique dans la
communauté
mettez vous dans la peau d'un
journaliste qui vient de l'extérieur qui
arrive tout à coup un kit saissac et qui
s'aperçoit que un des membres les plus
puissants du eg8 tresser nations
autochtones de cette façon là et ce
membre lors c'est le cas d' aller chez
ce qu'un jour regard sur l'arctique sera
écrit aussi 1 minute du tout je vais
dire on est en train de travailler sur
une traduction de ce projet là on est
petit tout en ce moment alors la réponse
est oui
au moins pour ceux repris pour la suite
des choses
halliche merci beaucoup pour ce regard
plein de tendresse de vérité se
regardent journalistes et ce regard de
femme qui adore profondément son marbre
à vous il ya tout plein d'autres choses
allaient voir notamment l en islande la
grand-mare y en a des tonnes et des
tonnes et si je veux poursuit on va
redescendre un petit peu au su de cette
fois et je vous cite james belgique est
un métis naskapis donc tout près de la
région de chez fusion entre le québec et
labrador vision nous a dit que nous ne
connaissions rien ou train etc on
t'offre est peu 1.1
ça fait 12 ans qu'on opère la ligne puis
ça vaut bien c'est mark twain qui
avaient dit aussi à l'époque on ne leur
a pas dit que c'est impossible donc ils
l'ont fait
guy bois un très un train qui s'appelle
piétine le vent du nord le candidat
aubry c'est un trait et qui existe
depuis 1956 mais qui porte ce nom là
depuis seulement 2005
bon on a acheté une portion du train en
2005 mais on a commencé à les opérer en
2006 qu'est ce que c'est ce train là
c'était construit en 1956 sur le
territoire d ea nous et ça faisait 7 sél
schefferville et pourquoi parce qu'on
venait d'ouvrir une mine à schefferville
point de schefferville en plein
territoire qui nous est d'ailleurs c'est
un guide inouk qui avait
justement indiquer où était une des
principales mines de fer aubenas qui
étaient là qui était propriété de l'art
allemand et on sait que brian mulroney
qui allait devenir premier ministre du
canada 84 a été président de la société
donc qu'est ce qui est arrivé dans les
années 2005 la québec labrador qui est
la compagnie qui administre cette ligne
de chemin de fer badine où on ne peut
pas continuer dans ces conditions là il
faut que vous les i nous il faudrait que
vous preniez une partie de cette ligne
ça nous permettrait d'avoir accès à des
subventions pour le transport en région
éloignée qui est un programme général
qui tamisent de sebha tous les canadiens
non seulement aux nations autochtones
donc les autochtones se sont mises
ensemble quatre communautés il y avait
trois chapes malioténam c'est exactement
la région de sept îles ensuite lysine ou
de la glande et ensuite les innu de
matinée coche et ensuite inscrit pique
les naskapis de notre politique
kawawachikamach c'est là où james bérubé
aînés et à partir de 2006 on a pris
cette portion qui part à peu près de
wabush et qui se rend jusqu'à
schefferville qui à peu près 200 km qui
appartient maintenant aux hinault et
qu'est-ce qu'on transporte on transporte
d'abord des gens c'est très important il
ya 15000 personnes qui chaque année
vaucher faut revivre cette île où
s'est-il schaeffer's
c'est beaucoup moins cher en trinquet en
avion va écouter en avion c'est 1200 $
aller-retour ils achètent ces chiffres
auraient alors la dernière fois que je
suis à la chaîne ça a coûté 850 dollars
c'est vous dire oui on est vraiment dans
d'autres proportions donc quinze mille
personnes mais c'est aussi chez ford usa
désenclave parce que tout ce qui
s'appelle nourriture matériaux de
construction dentifrice bref tout ce qui
met tout ce qui ce qui arrive à 7 6 2 7
6 à schefferville passe par ce train
repart ce trail est sympa exclusivement
une propriété avec bonbons des blancs
qui opère une grande majorité des gens
qui travaillent ce qu'ils font
fonctionner puis je parle pas seulement
des opérateurs et des frais 9,28 je
parle
administration de la gestion de ski sans
autochtone même si on prend fait et
cause et c'est une propriété là oui tout
à fait 80% de transport chez watson 80%
sont des autochtones c'est à dire
essentiellement d ea nous aider naskapis
quelques-uns d'autres nations se sont
aussi joints cette compagnie là c'est
donc dire que bon les lits conducteurs
de train sont ils nous sont à ce qu'a
dit la même chose pour les chefs de
train la même chose pour les gens qui
entretiennent mirail et c est ce qu il
faut voir au delà de l'administration du
train c'est toute une nouvelle façon de
s'approprier le territoire
parce que quand le train est arrivé en
1956 il faut bien rappeler qu'à cette
époque là les autochtones étaient
interdits dans le train parce que le
train était exclu et est réservé
exclusivement aux travailleurs de la
renault et aux minerais alors peu à peu
après de multiples le ton a réussi du
côté des autochtones à pouvoir prendre
ce train
et là aussi ça a changé d habitude parce
que vous imaginez une famille innu qui
partait de sétif de oicha toi chape qui
veut dire la baie et d'ailleurs quand on
connaît bien c'est sûr on s'aperçoit que
c'est une grosse bête très sain immense
mais alors les gens partaient 10 mois
est essentiellement depuis je vous
dirais depuis la fin du 19e siècle que
l'activité économique essentiel d ea
nous c'était le trappage le commerce des
fourrures un conte rendait à l'habitude
son qui avait obtenu le monocoque de la
couronne britannique
donc à partir de la fin du 19e siècle
ont essentiellement ce qu'on faisait du
côté des innus et est des commerçants et
il traitait de nation à nation avec des
autres alors quand est arrivé le trait
maginez ça a changé d'avis parce que une
famille par exemple partait dow achatt
pour monter entre guillemets d'angoua de
à travers la rivière moisie 1 ghz appel
l'amista chypre c'est à dire la grande
rivière jusqu'à chez forêt de
schefferville ils allaient dans leurs
territoires respectifs une famille de
sept îles ou de oicha prenait
habituellement deux mois pour suivre
pour monter pour monter alors
qu'actuellement s'en prend 14 ou 15
heures
donc voyez ça a changé beaucoup la vie
et ça changeait aussi la forme
d'occupation du territoire
parce qu'actuellement au lieu de se
déplacer sur le territoire qu'on
s'installe sur le territoire et tu
m'étonnes qu'ils passent et vous voyez
le long du chemin de fer un tas de
petites maisons qui sont des
installations qui sont autant de petites
gares dont se servent les i nous alors
autrement dit tu prends ton billet et sa
faune et on fonctionne encore en mille
tons parle de l'industrie du train alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on dit tu m'arrête
au 184 au 1184 et puis ça se rend
jusqu'à 300 parce que la distance entre
cette idée chez taurus et 300 m cette
belle histoire que vous me racontez vous
allez éventuellement mais tu sens une
chez espace attaoui ce sera après les
fans c'est un reportage qu'on a fait
aussi pour le téléjournal de radio
canada parce que c'est très visuel
alors vous imaginez toute la notion du
tas 1
et vous quand on attendait parler de
cette mairesse inuit ben qu'est ce que
ça nous disait ça nous est oui
effectivement
ces gens là ont une notion du temps qui
est différent pourquoi les différents
cette notion du temps parce que les gi
ou territoires et face à l'immensité le
temps ce comment dire et pour royer
c'est comme si le temps était dans une
autre dimension c'est quelque chose qui
est très il nous est aussi un et les
choux et c'est tout à fait ça alors on
le voit son entrain et c'était drôle
parce qu'à côté de moi est vain non
autochtone qui descendait de ceux ci et
qui descendait de schaeffer yeux vers
c'était vers cet hymne est l'hôte de
coûts lille tourne en rond pizza mais
c'est aux rebelles ont ces dons mais non
alors vous imaginez ce que moi j'étais
en train d'assister finalement quelqu'un
dont la conception du temps était celle
postmoderne que conte actuellement c'est
à dire que s'il faut atteindre une demi
seconde après un clic sur notre souris
on trouve que c'est une éternité
alors vous imaginez ces gens là qui
prenait 2 mois pour monter dans leur
territoire
la nation combler complètement différent
et non seulement il prenait deux mois
pour monter dans le territoire mais une
fois installé dans le territoire il y
avait aussi l'installation d'un camp
principal
et par la suite les femmes et les
enfants demeurait au camp principal et
des hommes partaient pour un mois un
mois et demi eux allaient faire leur
ligne de trappes est allé poser des
pièges un peu partout les coller les
pièges ce drama sert exactement
et je vous inviterai ce bouton b là
dessus à lire les mémoires de pierre
esprit radisson et ne déployez justement
à faire de commerce de fourrures et qui
a fait avant dernier est mort en exil en
angleterre et lui il partait de trois
rivières et ses voyages du ray contre 3
ans et demi et 5 alors à dans une époque
d'instantanéité comme comme la nôtre
c'est quand même étonnant qu'on puisse
avoir accès s'est tenue à cette
dimension du temps qui est radicalement
différente et qui est porteuse aussi de
signification en termes de modes de vie
comment les modes de vie ont changé
alors quand on dit que le train à à 1,18
finalement de nouvelles façons d'occuper
le territoire on alors une preuve
aujourd'hui donc des campements c'est à
dire que l'isi nous continue à occuper
le territoire traditionnel mais en s'y
installant et là le gros projet pour
on va se servir de la ligne de chemin de
fer
on va y dérouler de la fibre optique
ça veut dire que le nitassinan
c'est-à-dire ce territoire traditionnel
telle qu'appelée par les et nous devons
être irriguée par le roi forêts plus tôt
c'est fou un peu plus tôt haaliche qui
travaille aussi qu'étudiant chaîne qui a
travaillé là bob qui savait travailler
aussi dans nord de la russie
vous avez travaillé en bolivie quelques
années où seulement est ce qu'il ya des
liens à faire entre les populations
autochtones bolivienne que vous avez
quoi avec qui vous avez travaillé
est-ce que vous avez le jus sur place la
liste rance
rien de moins rayonnement disait que le
fond spirituel des premières nations au
des autochtones en amérique est le même
c'était son hypothèse lui le lignite
jusqu aux mapuches exactement passant
par l'illumination du brésil et ailleurs
y avait une anecdote dans tristes
tropiques ou levi strauss on va voir le
ministre brésilien
je sais pas quoi des forêts etc
il lui dit écoutez ça fait deux ans que
j'étudie les populations autochtones ce
que vous voulez qu'on partage les
connaissances etc et de lui répondre le
ministre mais voyons dont les
autochtones ça n'existe pas ou bien il
n'y a que les brésiliens alors vous
imaginez
c'est un peu ça et vous voyez par
exemple moi je travaillais avec des kits
choix essentiellement sont les
descendants des incas ou de ceux qui ont
été conquis par les incas parce que les
incas étaient des mercenaires qui ont
conquis du sud je vous dirais de
l'équateur jusqu'au presqu'à la au nord
de l'argentine
alors les quais de choix ont
sensiblement l'aller les délais les
mêmes rituels par exemple le rapport à
la mère terre la pachamama ici c'est la
même chose avec ça il ya par exemple les
i nous donnait
des offrandes à la bartère est entre
autres du tabac alors que du côté de la
bolivie où des questions de personnes la
china autrement dit vous prenez un verre
d'alcool la première goutte c'est
toujours pour le terrain mais même quand
vous êtes en aviron immédiat des
boliviens
alors il ya sensiblement la même chose
avec en même temps beaucoup de
différences par exemple les autochtones
dans en bolivie les quêtes choix se
définissait beaucoup plus je dis bien
défini ces jeux vous revenir là dessus
beaucoup plus comme campesino comme
paysan parce que posséder la terre c'est
quelque chose de valorisant
donc il possédait la terre à partir de
mode d'une réforme agraire qui a eu lieu
en bolivie en 1952
donc pour eux il se définissait comme
avant tout campesinos m'est arrivé 1988
92 qui marquait le 500e anniversaire de
l'arrivée officielle d europe et en
amérique la conception du bien avant les
coffres ou bien avant 14 192 les mêmes
dans région propice toldo j les basques
étaient là depuis mines en bon donc il y
a quand même des différences par contre
je me suis entré tout jour qu'une
chenille nous étaient venus nous visiter
en bolivie elle était assise tout a
compté dans un parc national de bolivie
on teste
elle était assise et là tout à coup le
gardien du parc s'est approché et a
commencé à lui parler enquête choix il
était convaincu que certaines quêtes
choix et les excès et je me souviens des
inouk i qui sont venus parce qu'il y
avait un programme des changes de l'acdi
financé par l'acdi entre les autochtones
du nord les autochtones du sud et je me
souviens que j'étais avec un ancien de
malioténam qui était assis avec moi
pendant que les autres d'échanger de
l'argent est assis juste à côté de moi
dans la voiture puis il regarda d'or
pizza
quand je veux dire à ma femme qui a
autant d un site à me créer d'abord
parce que justement ça c'est un autre
phénomène on quand on parle de du
phénomène autochtone en bolivie on parle
de 55% la population fait sascha ce
n'est plus une mine aussi ici au québec
on est 2 5% et ont pour le canada nation
parle ou à peu près 2
2 5% mais aussi avec une grande
diversité ce qu'on oublie très souvent
au canada c'est qu'on parle des
autochtones comme cet humble monolithe
alors que ça n'a rien à voir il ya un an
mme incommensurable de langue de culture
il ya 60 nations 60 langues autochtones
sont montés l'église sous l'angle gère
alors à la fois il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de similitudes entre les
autochtones du nord et du sud puis à la
fois beaucoup de différences ou parlant
de l'andra terminant votre inoue votre
inuit à quoi sont ils si je vous demande
de dire merci c'est possible à canonique
jamais jamais jamais ces deux merci
beaucoup d'être passé je ne devais juste
vous dire en terminant on a reçu une
lettre de joyeux noël et bonne année de
monsieur gasmi lazare qui nous a écrit
de d'algérie alors vous pourrez la voir
sur le site souhait c'est celle-là je
vous remercie beaucoup gasmi nasa
shoqrana vous c'est très très gentil par
prétend nous écrire c'est tout pour
cette émission merci à vous d'avoir été
des nôtres on vous saluons vous embrasse
à tous de très joyeuses fêtes un joyeux
noël et bonne année de paix d'amitié
bonne année 2010 9 surtout de grâce ne
permettait pas d'accointances de
connaissances entre alcool cannabis et
volants ici raymond des marteaux merci
car tout le monde salue
[Musique]